abone ol
[Müzik]
e
Herkese merhabalar ben Cihan
önceki aşırı heyecanlıyım ittifakı da
büyük bir kalabalığa doğru konuşuyorum o
yüzden hata yaparsan Beni mazur görün
lütfen o yüzden baştan oluyorum Herkese
merhabalar ben Cihan
Bunun tam yirmi yıl önce
hikaye başladı diyebilirim
kendime şöyle bir şey dedim bir meslek
seçerken ne yapmalıyım Ya da nasıl bir
meslek seçmedim diye düşünürken
kesinlikle bunun bir görsel bir meslek
olacağını hayal ettim dedim ki ben
görsel bir şeyler üretmeliyim ve
insanlar ve ürettiğim şeyleri izlemeli
bakmalı ve bunun bunu güzel bulmalı hep
that
sonrasında grafiği önerdim dedim ki ya
ya grafik çok Benlik bir şey değil abla
dedim yaz masa başı bir sıkıcı galiba
deyip fotoğraf çekmeye başladım ve
sonraki galiba fotoğraf Sen beni anlatan
bir meslek olabilir sonrasında dedim ki
Okey ne yapabilirim Tabii ki makine
almalıyım Şimdi şöyle bir şey var
dedemden kalma Biz End makinem yok
Bizimki Ben ise bulabildiğim tek makine
vardı o da böyle küçücük dandik böyle
1.3 megapiksel böyle ekransız bir işlem
akinay the on fotoğraflar çekmeye
başladım Ancak şu vardı ilgi alanım bir
şekilde
bir klasik bana göre klasik liyim böyle
çiçek böcek bölü sümüklü çocuk falan
dansa dedim ki ben arkadaşlarıma
portrelerini çekmeliyim onları güzel
göstermeliyim diyerek başladım dedim ki
ben onların işte kıyafetlerini
düzenleyen kıyafetleri düzelteyim şimdi
saçlarını düzelteyim diyerek Onları
böyle güzelleştirmeye çalışıyorum böyle
başladı Hikayem diyebilirim
ve sonrasında Ben tam bir nişanda
çocuğum Ee Asosyal bir çocuktum
apartmanda büyüdüm bilgisayarla büyüdüm
ve hayatım hep bilgisayarda geçti
bilgisayarda araştırmalar yaparak falan
geçti şimdi devamlı bir şeyler
araştırıyordum o dönem fotoğrafı da
meraklı olduğundan dolayı böyle bloklara
giriyordum ve o zaman Tabi ki de dataya
ulaşma onu şu anki gibi çok zordu çok
kolay değildi bir tane Uslu bulguru
vardı ve onun böyle kendi dergilerini
tar attığı bir biblo vardı oradaki
fotoğrafları böyle indirerek kendime
gelecekte yapacağım hayal ettiğim
çekimleri kurguluyorum kendime bir
klasöre falan yapıyordu
ardından dışarıda Dolanıyorum bir kitap
şeye girdim
kitapçıda Translate adında bir dergi
gördüm bayıldı model gibi dedim ki yani
bu kadar güzel belki içindeki editörlü
şekiller portre çekimi çok sevmiştim
aynı zamanda Tabii ki de çok hevesliyim
Devamlı böyle do de geziyorum falan
böyle meşhur O köşede Nişancı bir mağaza
vardır bazılarınız bilir çok büyük böyle
pencerelere çok büyük biçimleri olan
fotoğrafları böyle büyük kullanıldı bir
mağazadır Burası dedim ki galiba Bir Gün
Bu fotoğrafları ben çekeceğim diye
kendine hedefler ve hayaller belirledim
yok Ancak Tabii ki de bir adım atmam
gerekiyordu bu şöyle oldu önce dedim ki
ben prensesler hayalim var Ben tesettüre
girmek istiyorum mailler attım
insanlarla iletişime girmeye çalıştım
nasıl olur ulaşırım diye hep kendimi
zorladım Hatta gittim merkezine gittim
mailler almaya çalıştım ve bir şekilde
orada Onları beni çağırdı burada 17
yaşındayım 17 ve 18 de bağlayan bir
yıldayız zamandayım de la ki Cihan Gel
bizimle çalış ama biple bölümünün ya
röportaj bölümünün fotoğrafını
çekebilirsin okey dedim ücretsiz ve
manasız bir şekilde orada başladım benim
için çok güzel zamanlarda o zaman Çünkü
şunu hatırlıyorum Bir röportaja
gidiyorsunuz ve 10 dakika da O kişiden
nasıl bir portre çıkarabilirmi hep
düşünüyorsunuz bu çok ciddi bir çalıştı
benim için Çünkü ben Asosyal biriydim
iletişimin çok iyi değildi ve bu şekilde
onlardan güzel o çıkarmaya çalışıyordu
Ancak şu vardı yetmeyen bir şey vardı o
da dedim ki kendime Ben kendimce bunu
profesyonel bir şekilde gel etmeliyiz
dedi ki ben fotoğraf bölümünde
okumalıyım fotoğraf okumalıyım ve hep
sanat içi olmadım dedim ve iki tane de
koydum kendimi Mimar Sinan ve Yıldız
Teknik
Mimar Sinan tam sınavına gireceğim gün
Yıldız Teknik kazandığımı öğrendim ve
Danet Okey ben yıldıza devam ediyorum
ancak Tabii ki de aşırı hevesliyim Bu
arada Yani bir haber geldi şimdi Hancım
böyle böyle biz işte yeni bir kampüsümüz
var burayı zamanlar buranın davutpaşaya
gitmek zorundasın hazırlık okuyacaksın
orada benim bütün hayallerim Altüst oldu
Neden derseniz şöyle Çünkü ben öncelikle
fotoğraf okuma hayaliyle hevesiyle hep
böyle böyle uyanıyorum ve dedim ki
fotoğraf okumadığım bir an önce bu bu
hazırlık kısmı biraz böyle bir
heveslerimi böyle bir erteleme sebep
oldu ya bu şöyle birşey oldu şimdi
çantasında bu Paşa gelmeyi falan böyle
çok şey yaptım kendime ama dedim ki Okey
Yapabileceğim bir şey yok yani ben bir
şekilde geleceğim işte da açıkçası ne
yaptım işte buraya geldim buraya
gelirken 8.13 şu katılıyorum 8.13 500
sayı Taksim'de yakalamanın gururunu
yaşıyordum Hatta otobüste uyumayı
öğrendim bu şekilde buraya geldim bir
şekilde bu yıllar geçti Yeni bir yıl
geçtim Bu sırada hemen bir araya kat
vermek istiyorum Bu dönemde
buraya gelirken hazırlık dönemi
zamanında
bir Pr Ajansı bir hafta içleri ajansında
Parti fotoğrafçılığa başladım onları
düzenlediği partiler değirmenlerde
partiler çekmeye başladım şıma açıkçası
şöyle hayalim miydi değildi ama bir
şekilde harçlığımı çıkarmak istiyordum
hem de mesleğin farklı bir Dalını
deneyimlemek istiyordum harçlığımı
çıkarırken aynı zamanda 12 ya ben bu
mesleği yapacaksanız bu dolu yapacaksam
iyi bir şekilde yapmalıyım nasıl
değiştirebilirim baktım fotoğraflara şu
klasik Flash da böyle eğlenen Parti
fotoğraflar var insanlara eğlence park
fotoğrafları dedi ki ben böyle çekmedim
Ben
Parti'den hikaye çıkarmalıyım Ben
İnsanların eline kendi de onların işte
detayını çekmeli ve bir hikayesi olmalı
diye kendime hep bunu aşıladım o da
neden
bu çünkü o dönem fotoğraflara bakarken
fotoğrafları araştırırken amerikalısı
numarası fotoğraflarına denk geldim
kendisi
1900 çok pardon İki Dünya Savaşı zamanı
bir savaş maviyken
1960-1961 70'li yıllarda Amerika ve
Avrupa'da sosyetenin muhteşem en
eğlenceli lüks partilerin fotoğraflarını
çekti
aktive açıkçası bunun silme arasın bu
izlenimci yaklaşımı benim için çok bir
ilerleyeceğim yolu çok güzel bir yol
gösterici oldu diyebilirim
ve sonra silme nasıl bir tane sözüne iyi
denk geldi mi bu söz aslında Hem beni
değiştirdi hem de sonrasında bir moddom
oldu diyebilirim
fotoğraf renk etrafı people doing
ekstraktif Kanki ne traktör places bu
aslında
moda fotoğrafçılığının yaptığımız
mesleğin tamamıyla bir mottosu
diyebiliriz gerçekten insanları güzel
göstermeye çalışıyoruz doğal göstermeye
çalışıyoruz ve Bunları gerçekten kendimi
kendi yarattığımız dünya içinde
sunuyoruz diyebilirim
bu beni çok güzel bir mutluydu
ancak sonrasında
bu Tabii ki de dedim ki ben Parti
fotoğrafçılığına başka bir şekilde başka
bile uzatmalıyım aklıma şu geldi
Türkiye'de çok yapılmıyor ama dünyada
çok fazla örneğini gördüm kulis
fotoğrafçılığına yöneldim
şimdiki Ben ben modanın aslında moda
fotoğrafını belgeseli sayılabilecek kuş
fotoğrafçılığı yapmalıyız ıvesa bu
oluşumuna Gittim defilelere gittim orada
kulislere girmek için yalvardım gizli
gizli girdiğim olduğu milletin Access
kartlarını çalıp girdim falan da olmuştu
vardır Hatta bu şekilde polislere
girerek kulis fotoğrafçılığı yapmaya
başladık benim için çok keyifli düşünkü
insan ve moda vardı bu yüzden çok Keyif
alarak sayısı defileye girdim Hatta
tarihinde ilk defa Miss Turkey besleyici
çektim benim için çok keyifliydi her şey
gördüğünüz gibi
i e sonrasında
hemen bir araya girmek istiyorum Bu
arada fakültemiz iki yılın dayım Yıldız
Kampüs deyim ara hayallerimi yaşıyorum
arkadaşlarınla sana konuşuyorum ve bir
dersteyiz Bu benim şansıma Kırılma
Noktası dediniz noktalardan biri bu bir
dersteyiz fotoğraf dersiniz hocamız bize
bir ulaşım temalı bir fotoğraf gösterdi
bu fotoğraf sayı fotoğrafta dedi ki
fotoğrafta şu vardı Bir kağıt
toplayıcısı geniş açılı fotoğrafı Kağıt
toplayıcısı böyle bir düz duruyor şimdi
o dönem belgesel fotoğraf ile ilgilenen
sadece moda fotoğrafı ilgilenmiyorum
bana bir şekilde fotoğraf yanlış geldi
beğenmedim ve tepkim ona göstermek
istedim de Hocam ben bu fotoğrafı Doğru
bulmuyorum Çünkü biz fotoğraf
öğrencileri dünyayı farklı görmeliyiz
farklı şeylerle ile etmeliyiz insanları
sanatımızı bu şekilde gösteriniz Biz
dümdüz şeyler çekemeyiz diye kendimi ona
anlatmaya çalıştım Ancak bu Tabi şu
sonucu çıkardı Ben de galiba çok severek
hevesli Bir şekilde geldim Bu okulda da
muhteşem temel sanat eğitimi aldım Ancak
şu eksikti Sektörel bir deneyim
kazanamayacağını düşün bu ve sonrasında
okulla karşı hislerin biraz azaldı ve
sonrasında uzaklaştım Bu benim kendi
içimde kurduğum bir tartışmayı da
aslında diyebilirim sonrasında çok kısa
bir süre sonra
bir bu polis fotoğrafçılığı yaparken ben
çalıştım ajansın şeyinde ve bilgisayar
ekranında çektiğim bir fotoğraf bu
fotoğraf açık kalmıştı bu ve o sırada
Ofisi ziyaret eden el dairesine Genel
Yönetmeni düşün görmüş bu fotoğrafı
gördükten sonra diyor ki ben bu
fotoğrafı çeken çocuklar tanışmak
istiyorum Bu kim ve sonrasında diyor ki
bizim Allah ise çalışabilir Ben 50
hangisine çalışmaya bu şekilde bas
başladım ve benim için asla tam bir
turning Point dediğimiz şey aslında bir
nevi ribon hikayemi başlangıcı
diyebilirim Çünkü elde el dergisi bir
moda dergisi ydi ha ve kurduğum
dergilerden bir
tanesiydim ve onun o Dergiye girmem ile
birlikte bütün dergilerin Bir nevi
kapısı açıldı diyebilirim markalarla
çalışmaya başladım kozmopolit anla
harper's Bazaar ve sonrasında Volvo
çalışmaya başladım ben için her şeyi çok
hızlı ilerliyordu 19 yaşındaydım yirmi
yaşıma doğru gidiyordum Ve açıkçası bir
şey vardı o da asistanlık yapmanın çok
önemli olduğu bir meslek yolundayken
asistanı yapmadan bir anda sektör
atılmıştı mi
O çok koydum aslında Çünkü hiçbir şey
bilmiyordum Işık bilmiyordum çünkü set
dönemim yoktu iletişim nasıl kurulur onu
bilmiyordum çünkü bir Hocam yoktu Bana
öğretebilecek müşterilerle direkt
iletişimi Ben kuruyordum e bütçeleri Ben
hazırlıyordum çekimi bitiyordu ertesi
günü çekme ben gidiyordum fotoğrafları
ben yapıyordum ve bu süreç içinde
Gerçekten çok zorlandım ancak biliyorum
ki
sonrasında geriye dönüp baktığımda dedim
ki ben galiba bunu iki yapmışım kahve
iki kendi başına bir şeyler yapmışım
dedim ve bunları tam sorgularken Şuna da
Anladım hala daha anlamı anlıyorum
anlamaya çalışıyorum diyebilirim Bence
fotoğraf çekmek cfo Fotoğrafçılık
fotoğraf çekmekten ibaret değil bence
Fotoğrafçılık tam bir iletişim Hatta
iletişimin neredeyse yüzde doksanı
kaplayan bir meslek Çünkü
o zaman içinde şuna yaşadığım oldum çok
bozuktu Kız arkadaşımdan ayrıldım ve
aynı zamanda her tipini seçe gittim
Dedim ki Okey ben bu anları kendimde
bırakmalıyım ST girdiğim anda her şey
bırakmadı bütün umutsuzluğumu
mutsuzluğuma bırakmalıyım dedim ve
ardından problemler Yaşadım ve öğrendim
ki problemleri problem değilmiş gibi aks
etmem gerekiyor çünkü mesleğin cilvesi
Aslında buydu ve insanlarla iletişime
girmeye çalıştım ünlülerle hep güzel
iletişim kurmaya çalıştım güler yüzlü
olmaya çalıştım ve sonrasında onlar
tarafından tercih edilen bir fotoğrafçı
oldum Çünkü iletişime her zaman güçlü
etmeye çalıştım ve bu iletişimi birlikte
her zaman etrafıma şunu anlattım dedim
ki her zaman ama her zaman bu biri neden
rahatsız oluyorsanız onu o an söyleyin
beni çok seviyorsanız onu ona söyleyin
Eğer bir görüşmede ya da bir toplantıda
oraya ait olmadığını hissediyorsanız
orayı O an terk edin önümüz açıktır bir
hatta dedim ki eğer bir işinize
öğreniyor sanız sonrasında işinizin
patronu olun ve sonrasında Sokakta bir
hayvan gördüğünüzde onu seven ona yardım
edin kendime hep Bunu aşıladım
arkadaşlarıma bunu aşladım
ve sonra geri dönüp baktığımda
İyi o zaman zarfında neler yaptığıma
bu Nişantaşı'nda o malzeme önünden
geçerken kendi fotoğraflarına bakıyordum
bu ve sonrasında dedim ki
mi Evet prensesler gibi bir dergi ne
kapağını çekemedim
bu ama hayallerimin ötesinde bir
derginin vok adisyonun Japon adisyonun
fotoğrafını çektim kapağını çektim Bu
benim için çok büyük bir Gurur duy
UV
vb şimdi düşünüyorum bundan buraya
geldiğim ilk zamanlarda Davutpaşa geldim
ilk zamanlarda
8.13
no otobüsü Yakalayarak buraya gelirken
tam 17 yıl sonra sizin gibi güzel
insanların karşısında konuşmak için
tekrar buraya geliyor olmak benim için
gurur verici teşekkür ederim